we're not allowed in here usually
because it's 19 plus in the Commodore so
it's will see like our band or favorite
bands will post like a tour poster I can
use like governor come on baby please
let us into your shows
[Applause]
[Music]
but it's good because the music industry
is getting younger which is great for us
and there's definitely you know having
to fight that expectation that people
have you know because you're young you
will sound a certain way or you have a
certain way of looking at music that
maybe you know they don't take you
seriously but yeah I think it's
something you have to fight against but
we're just gonna keep doing our thing
and by doing that I think yeah combatted
we got carded at our own show like I
don't even have a card thing to show you
formed in 2017 in Vancouver the band has
just released its first EP stout made
their TV debut on Jimmy Kimmel wowed
fans at Osheaga and their video for city
boy well it has over 2 million views and
Counting on YouTube
[Music]
I try not to think about success as a
thing I just kind of go along and do ya
whatever we can artistically like number
of followers number of views number of
hits none of that none of that
personally matters to me as long as I'm
having a good time and there's some
people out there enjoying our music
that's that's what means a lot